vous parler tout à l'heure de longévité
des présentateurs notamment de
télévision alors lui en termes de
longévité il a battu absolument tous les
records c'est-à-dire qu'il est né en
1929 il est il est devenu voyou à l'âge
de 16 de 17 18 ans et il est mort en
2019 j'ai compté ça fait à peu près 10
quinquennat les hommes politiques au
bout de quinquennat il saute les
réalisateurs je sais pas les animateurs
les animateurs bon ça va vite ça va vite
lui il a tenu environ 50 ans pendant 50
ans le haut du pavé alors évidemment il
avait des clés pour ça et d'ailleurs il
me le disait il disait moi si j'ai tenu
le haut du pavé c'est aussi que j'ai su
partager mais il y avait aussi c'est
quelqu'un qui était bon il a été on va
dire en France il a été pour moi le
parrain d'éparins c'est-à-dire qu'il a
été le patron du milieu français pendant
30-40 ans il régnait aussi bien à Paris
qu'à Marseille donc c'était quelqu'un de
voilà qui régnait forcément un petit peu
par la peur mais je veux dire la
dernière fois que je l'ai vu il me dit
parce que faut dire au téléspectateur
qui le savent pas qu'en 1977 cet homme a
pris 22 balles dans le corps et sur les
sorties vivantes grâce à des médecins en
or sans doute mais de d'où sont surnom
l'immortel donc à partir le match le
match ça vient de du corse le matou le
matou en Corse c'est pas le fou dingue
c'est celui qui n'a pas de limite et
donc c'est quelqu'un je finissais sur la
peur c'est quelqu'un qui donc à cause de
cet de cette de ces balles qu'il avait
pris en 77 avait le bras droit qui avait
un peu flanché et ce de ce jour-là il a
appelé il a appris à tirer avec la main
gauche et la dernière fois que je l'ai
vu il m'a dit mais tu crois pas Frédéric
hein regarde il s'est mis comme ça elle
m'a dit mais là-bas tu me mets un gars
là-bas à 45 mètres je le touche donc
c'est quelqu'un qui quand même pratiqué
un peu la terreur sauf que en tant qu'
époux je crois que Christine tu l'as tu
as connu l'autre homme c'est c'est comme
toujours
pour noter les spectateurs pour les et
le plus vite pour les chroniqueurs aussi
quand on dit c'était le parrain des
parents eux ils aimeraient bien savoir
c'était quoi son métier au jour le jour
son métier en tout cas Christie dans La
Teste je veux dire et il a jamais manqué
d'argent il a jamais compté l'argent qui
dépensait il a toujours tout payé en
espèces pendant toute sa vie et quand il
allait au restaurant avec des amis avec
des gens un peu c'est lui qui payait
toujours c'est de générosité comme ça
donc le métier qu'il faisait en gros il
s'est retrouvé à l'âge de 17 ans en
prison mais pour une raison qui est qui
va vous surprendre c'est qu'il avait
frappé son beau-père qui avait un petit
peu malmené ça la fille de dans sa
compagne donc en fait il avait voulu
venger cette femme il avait frappé dans
un café il avait il avait trouvé en tôle
et quand il est sorti de prison il a dit
en gros en prison tu as deux solutions
soit tu te fais excusez-moi l'expression
trop et le cul soit tu massacres et bien
moi c'est comme ça qui me l'a dit c'est
des guillemets et bien moi j'ai choisi
de massacrer et donc à partir de là il
s'est dit et c'est vraiment le message
qu'il a qu'il a fait passer à tout le
monde il a tenu ce sac toute sa vie ce
cap c'est il a dit ce sont les voyous
qui vont me faire vivre ce sont les
voyous qui vont me faire manger et donc
il a passé sa vie à racketter les voyous
pour racketter les voyous il faut être
un peu un peu au dessus dedans c'est
pour ça que on l'appelle le parrain
d'épargne parce que précisément il a il
a mangé sur le dos des voyous il a passé
sa vie on lui donnait en fait on lui
donnait de l'argent il y avait les
cercles de jeux à Paris c'était un peu
l'huile le grand boss il y avait
Marseille parce qu'il était entre Paris
et Marseille il est né à Toulouse au
départ c'est pas à marseillais
contrairement mais il avait du sang
Corse
il était le roi à Marseille mais aussi à
Paris donc il a mangé c'est pas
quelqu'un qui il a pas braqué des
fourgons c'est pas beaucoup de gens
alors il a tué quelques personnes et on
leur raconte
dans le livre on raconte les trois les
trois meurtres essentielles qui la
commis et à chaque fois ça fait basculer
l'histoire du milieu français dire les
frères Guerini dirigés régné à Marseille
depuis la guerre il arrive les frères
Guerini élimine un de ses meilleurs amis
qui était un ancien et écoutez bien
commissaire de police du
contre-espionnage français qui avait
pendant la résistance chasser les
Allemands à Marseille et qui était
rentré dans le banditisme et qui était
qui avait investi dans les dans les jeux
et qui était devenu son ami ce policier
cet ancien policier des froquets on va
dire se fait tuer il décide de le venger
et il tue les frais guerriers et ça fait
basculer exactement c'est pour ça
attention
c'est pas bien mais voilà il y a un
cadre c'est pas bien voilà il faut mais
bon il sait pas voilà il y a un cadre
c'est et puis après c'est important de
le dire après après
gaëtanzanpin c'est c'est son ami euh
c'était son rival et son ami à Marseille
et un jour donc il sort d'une partie de
cartes il rentre chez lui en 1977 il est
il est tard le soir il est attendu il y
a trois gars qui sortent de sous les
bosquets et puis il arrose de 22 balles
parce que je disais tout à l'heure et il
croit qu'il est mort il y en a un c'est
galette de temps en temps qui est
persuadé d'avoir réussi son coup il
soulève il retire sa cagoule pour partir
sauf qu'il est pas mort
sauf que il a vu qui lui avait tiré
dessus mais c'est mon ami j'aurais
jamais cru j'aurais jamais cru ça il dit
il se dit mais j'aurais jamais cru ça de
mon ami il y avait dans un pas été son
ami à partir de là il est évident que
tous les amis de temps en temps ils vont
y passer que la guerre va durer 20 ans à
Marseille alors c'est pas voilà il tue
pas des gens comme ça pour le plaisir
c'est c'est dans le cadre on va dire de
son métier c'est ça et pour régner comme
ça on peut pas non plus on peut pas non
plus être à 12 agneau c'est pas possible
c'est voilà
parce que voilà tu le dis c'est pas non
plus voilà c'est c'est parce qu'il faut
faire mais je vais ajouter quelque chose
sur le sol le caractère de du personnage
c'est c'est moi j'en ai rencontré
beaucoup d'évolus ça fait 30 ans que
j'écris sur ce milieu là c'est
probablement le plus érudit que j'ai
rencontré c'est un homme intelligent
cultivé je dis ça parce que je pense que
ça va surprendre les gens c'est
quelqu'un qui lisait qui vous empruntait
des bouquins pour les lire c'est
quelqu'un qui pouvait parler de
n'importe quel sujet il faut demander à
Christine je veux dire il lui a appris
énormément de choses il est allé il est
pas forcément allé à l'école mais c'est
il s'est cultivé donc c'était vraiment
quelqu'un qui est au-dessus de pardon
non c'est extrêmement important parce
que ça permettait de ça lui a permis
d'être ami aussi bien avec un indolent
c'est-à-dire amidalain Delon c'était le
meilleur ami d'Alain Delon depuis les
années 60 mais ça lui aussi permis de
discuter d'homme à homme et les yeux
dans les yeux avec des hommes politiques
à des hommes politiques à Marseille et à
Paris ça lui a permis de négocier on va
dire avec des notables des hommes
d'affaires donc d'être en fait le milieu
on se demande moi parfois je me suis
demandé pourquoi on appelle ça le milieu
français mais c'est bien parce qu'ils
sont au milieu et ces voyous étaient au
carrefour des notables de la rue de la
classe politique et de show business
c'était ça c'était ça le milieu et lui
il était vraiment au milieu et il avait
la capacité de dialoguer avec tout le
monde et en 1980 ça c'est une anecdote
que Christine raconte en 1980 il a une
Rolls François Mitterrand vient d'être
très bien être élu à l'Élysée pour son
premier septa et lui il se balade avec
sa Rolls avec une cocarde bleu blanc
rouge ouais c'est quelqu'un qui était
introduit on va dire dans tous les
milieux on sait pas un voyou tout à fait
ordinaire comment vous l'avez connu à
Marseille à l'opéra à l'Opéra comment
comme ça il avait juste le bar derrière
la boutique
69 69 je sais que vous avez vous avez 41
ans d'écart et vous vous aviez fait le
calcul 28
franchement j'aurais jamais cru qu'il
avait 69 non mais
épouser Jacky Imbert non vous saviez qui
c'était ou pas du tout non franchement
non pas du tout vous l'avez dit non
parce que je n'habite pas à Marseille
je savais pas du tout qu'il était et je
l'ai su vraiment quand il est rentré en
prison
[Rires]
[Musique]
et j'avais fini mon stage
dans un institut
et
quoi
de Jacky parce que c'est c'était un
seigneur
et après je travaillais j'étais enceinte
de notre fils il avait été incarcéré
pour qu'elle fait la contrebande de
cigarettes avec la mafia
russement oui difficile parce que vous
vous retrouvez seul mais quand vous
l'avez rencontré au départ vous n'avez
pas demandé ce qu'il faisait dans la vie
des retraités
[Rires]
j'imagine non parce que j'ai toujours
travaillé dans ma vie je me suis pas
mariée pour lui pour ni pour son argent
ni personne de confiance
c'était difficile pour lui la prison oui
parce que j'étais enceinte de un mois et
faire ma grossesse seule entre
guillemets
quand il était quand il parlait tout le
monde se taisait en prison ah oui ça
c'est sûr
c'est que Christine était enceinte parce
que pour le reste il a été pris en main
on va dire par un peu tout le monde et
la même il a même un moment donné
distribué il est important il a fait
rentrer dans la prison des sucettes des
Chupa Chupa et il a distribué ça à tous
les surveillants et tous les
surveillants se baladaient avec leur
Chupa Chupa et ensuite il a lancé la
mode de ses sucettes il a besoin de
lancer deux modes en prison la mode des
claquettes des claquettes tout le monde
s'est mis en claquette il a lancé la
mode des jeux pas tout le monde s'est
mis en avec la Chupa et puis il y a les
petits jeunes caillent d'aujourd'hui qui
était en adoration devant lui qui est
encore qui ont commencé à lui proposer
la protection le machin le truc il avait
pas besoin de protection mais s'il y
avait quelqu'un qui bronchait contre lui
à un moment donné il y avait toujours
des petits jeunes c'est un peu comme
dans le film Le prophète mais on verrait
quoi le petit jeune qui intervenait qui
voilà et puis bon j'avais allé aussi
Alain Delon exactement
vous racontez qui fascinait les femmes à
tel point qu'il y avait des files
d'attente de femmes pour venir le voir
ça c'était difficile à vivre quand même
pour vous il y avait une sorte de
jalousie féminine par rapport à votre
mari ces femmes là étaient en fascinées
par le parrain des parrain oui parce que
je me suis posé la question avec 41 ans
d'écart qu'est-ce qui
il y avait un problème je comprenais pas
autant de femmes
Frédéric nous a dit voilà c'était quand
même c'était quand même c'est dur
Jacky et avec vous c'était tout le
contraire il était comment par exemple
dans le privé parce que c'est vrai que
c'est ça qu'on a envie de savoir par le
privé je repasse ces chaussettes
repasser les chaussettes
les chaussettes les chemises
il fallait qu'il ait son parfum au
fraîche de Dior toutes les semaines
par la vie je pourrais dire j'ai vécu 20
ans 17 ans
dans son lit dans son lit absolument
exceptionnel dans ce milieu là c'est ça
exactement
dans la rue avec trois balles dans le
corps et lui il est mort dans son lit ça
dit aussi voilà s'il était un petit peu
notamment sur nous de l'immortel
absolument c'est à cause des 22 balles
voilà et puis effectivement le fait de
mourir dans son lit c'est tellement
exceptionnel dans ce milieu là que voilà
ça le classe ça le met mais dans la vie
privée tu racontes c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui d'abord
très simple après
dans la vie intime c'est très simple ce
ne prenez pas la tête
regardez un peu non
à la maison qui venait donc
voilà des personnalités du showbize
j'imagine que quand on est un parrain
comme ça forcément quelqu'un veut
prendre ta place ou alors je te
regardais le parrain au cinéma est-ce
que la nuit vous aviez peur parce que
beaucoup enfin toutes les nuits qu'on
vienne vous j'imagine que des gens ils
voulaient du mal non on n'a jamais eu de
carte on dort mais les volets ouverts
[Musique]
il a déjà éliminé tous ses ennemis donc
il y en a plus donc il est tranquille il
a déjà éliminé tous les ennemis donc il
y a plus évidemment il a il est sur ses
gardes il est forcément armé il sait se
défendent etc mais j'ai l'impression que
avec Christine c'est ça qui m'a
stupéfait dans le récit qu'elle m'a
qu'elle en fait c'est que il a il l'a
rassuré pleinement et jamais elle était
inquiète s'il y avait un besoin d'argent
bon tu pouvais te servir des petites
liasses comme ça de temps en temps
de temps en temps j'en prenais un petit
alors vous en parlez de manière très
romantique prétendre et c'est assez beau
mais moi j'aimerais bien savoir
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit à votre fils
en fait est-ce que vous parlez de tout
de son papa de toutes ces zones d'ombre
aussi est-ce que vous lui dites que
pendant plusieurs décennies il a été
patron d'une sorte de mafia marseillaise
ou non franchement non
il avait 15 ans il y a que maintenant
qui s'aperçoit qu'il était son père donc
il découvre maintenant qu'ils ne sont
pas là aussi on en parlait pas
d'ailleurs il me Shaquille refusait que
je lui achète des pistolets petit un
moment donné je lui disais mais tu veux
quoi que je lui achète une poupée Barbie
c'est vrai qu'un jour tu lui as acheté
un pistolet il l'a détruit il voulait
pas que son fiston à 12-13 ans se balade
avec une arme à feu
sur ses activités professionnelles pour
vous protéger ou est-ce que vous disiez
tout
au début il me disait rien c'est après à
force avec les années
quand tu reçois la maison Robert louer
Dreyfus qui était patron de l'OM à
l'époque
à la maison le patron de l'Olympique de
Marseille à Fuveau elle apprend beaucoup
plus tard je me mets chez lui des hommes
qui sont armés et vous voyez qu'ils sont
armés qui posent leurs fringues et tout
enfin vous êtes là avec des carottes
râpées vous voyez que des mecs ont tous
une arme il y a aucun problème dans
votre tête
chez moi il y a personne qui est venue
avec des armes
[Musique]
d'accord
quand il voit la projection il dit mais
je suis pas l'abbé Pierre c'est Labé
Pierre lui
parce que ça désigne quand même pas mal
de temps
donc il a pas trop aimé comment ça se
fait qu'il est fait si peu de prison
parce qu'il a quand même
mais il a pas aimé du tout c'est bien
suivi
le film je suis désolé moi aussi
peu de prison
parce qu'il est meilleur que les autres
deux parce qu'à l'époque il y a pas de
caméra surveillance de téléphone
portable
et puis 3 c'est pas il a pas braqué des
fourgons il a il a tenu le milieu
français donc il était des voyous c'est
est-ce que vous voyez un voyou ou un ou
un fraudeur fiscal qui se fait racketter
par Jacky le match aller voir le
commissariat en disant son idée de génie
son idée de ça a été quand il est sorti
de saison dire les voyous vous me
rendrez voilà c'est-à-dire qui on voyou
donc forcément il porte pas exactement
bah oui sinon tu peux envoyer non c'est
ça mais si tu fais de l'Office
préféré les voyous les voyous sont trop
tués entre eux plutôt que
il faut il faut assurer il faut assumer
c'est ça parce que ils peuvent tous
avoir envie de te tuer donc à partir de
là il faut
parfois quand même vous raconter dans le
livre c'était compliqué il était très
autoritaire à un moment vous allez
déposer un chèque en achetant quelque
chose vous revenez à la maison et vous
dit plus jamais ça il envoie quelqu'un
mettre du liquide à la place du chèque
et vous dit plus donc ça rigolait pas
toujours il avait un côté par un des
parents parfois à la maison ça m'a
beaucoup arrangé comme tu m'as dit
reprends le chèque
il était parfois dur avec vous aussi
2000 euros vous dites par mois de c'est
ça pour vos courses
vous le regardez à chaque fois avec les
yeux de fin voilà de l'admiration de
l'amour donc vraiment les la vie qui
vous a off
vous avez vous avez été vraiment
vraiment heureuse oui vraiment les
doutes les craintes les peurs malgré
la part d'ombre vous avez vraiment été
heureuse et si c'était à refaire vous
referiez ça oui franchement oui je suis
désolé madame mais c'est très gênant ça
fait 10000
et en plus je mets une telle heure que
vous m'aimez beaucoup ça me touche mais
on en parle tous comme ça de depuis 10
minutes comme si c'était quelqu'un de
bien il avait une idée ça reste un
criminel
il faut peut-être
qu'il a dérangé à un moment donné c'est
de se lever à 5h du matin pour aller
chez les piciers pour acheter des
carottes bio
aller nourrir ses chevaux parce que
c'était par ailleurs en fait c'est un
personnage qui était vraiment piloté des
avions
il était capitaine de bateau il a été
quand il a décidé de faire du cheval à
un moment donné de se mettre au cheval
et il est devenu champion de France du
trop atelier en 1973 mais adoré les
animaux là tu réponds pas à la question
non
c'est de se lever à 5h du matin
et vous l'avez aimé j'en doute pas mais
on est quand même en train de dire
depuis tout à l'heure ah il était gentil
il était douille acheter des carottes et
Machin il a quand même tué des gens
c'était un voyou c'était le parrain de
la peine enfin il y a un moment en place
quand même c'est ça reste un criminel
même quand tu tues à voyou tu es un
criminel est-ce que ça c'est bizarre
parce qu'il y a une criminel qui quand
même qu'à chaque fois qu'on voyait Jacky
n'importe où à Paris parce qu'on allait
souvent Fouquette parce que j'ai mis
entre guillemets aussi les portes ben je
peux vous garantir que un tapis rouge
on l'aimait en fait c'était pas présent
ce qu'on raconte aujourd'hui dans mais
c'était pas présent à la maison c'est ça
qu'elle veut dire c'est ce que je
raconte dans le livre là tout cet aspect
je pense que jamais il lui a dit je sais
pas je crois même que quand vous alliez
à Cassis il te montrer à peine il
passait à peine devant l'endroit où il
fait tirer dessus je dirais il en
parlait pas ça criminel monsieur
pour vous c'est un criminel pour moi
après ça ces activités pour vous c'était
c'est un travail comme un autre
moi quand je l'ai rencontré c'était
sabelote chez tonton derrière c'était
les chevaux c'était le bateau Alain
Mireille aussi on a vu Mireille Darc au
téléphone voilà mais qui veut pas que
son fils fasse le même métier que lui ah
non pas du tout donc ça veut dire bien
qu'il avait quand même un destin
particulier et plutôt accidentogène mais
je lui avais demandé si tu as refaire tu
le tu l'aurais refait il m'a dit non pas
du tout
destinée à ça en fait Jacky est-ce que
est-ce que un jour par amour vous lui
avez demandé d'arrêter tout ça mais il
avait été chat arrêté
quand vous vous étiez avec lui il avait
tout d'abord
les restos machin et tout ça tout le
monde tourne tout le monde payait pour
un peu sa protection et tout ça donc
évidemment
que vous écrivez dans le livre que il
vous assure oui j'ai tué des gens mais
c'est parce qu'il le méritait vous
écrivez ça ça c'est quand même
fort peut-être aussi choquant vous
semblez pas non mais non mais non mais
non parce que non mais c'est intéressant
parce qu'elle parle parce que en fait
c'est des deux histoires dont on parlait
oui je pense que tu parlais Christine du
fait qu'il est tué celui qui a voulu qui
a voulu l'assasser ceux qui ont voulu
l'assassiner et puis l'autre affaire
dont on a parlé son meilleur ami
mais c'est tout ça fait trois morts
enfin c'est tout
c'est l'histoire du banditisme français
en tout cas c'est un beau livre
mais je trouve qu'on en parle de manière
vous en parle de manière avec un sourire
un peu les gens c'est pas ne fais pas la
bio
dans tous les couples il y a des il y a
des disputes parfois violentes est-ce
que quand ça vous est arrivé vous avez
eu peut-être un jour peur de lui sachant
ce qu'il était capable de faire dans
d'autres circonstances une fois j'ai eu
peur c'est une bonne question
parce que je
je voulais le quitter
c'est passé c'était au Maroc
et voilà mais après
pourquoi parce qu'il me trompait
à Marrakech
donc j'ai pris mon fils et je suis
rentrée après vous êtes remis ensemble
non non
vous aviez peur de quoi de sa réaction
chez les cramé comment je travaillais
mon fils était à la maison et il avait
oublié son téléphone
je vous le dis c'est une merde
[Rires]
insupportable insupportable et donc oui
et donc et donc vous l'avez dit quoi
la fille elle lui disait je t'aime oui
alors non mais c'est une expression
[Musique]
sur 86 ans et vous êtes rendu compte
avec son tel qu'il avait plusieurs
plusieurs maîtresses plusieurs maîtresse
et donc et donc
quand vous lui avez dit parce que ça
c'est intéressant
j'ai dit je prends mon Jacky
parce qu'il y avait son téléphone ça va
attendu 40 mais il dit quoi ah oui alors
il rentrait m'avait acheté l'elliptique
vous savez pour faire le sport il me dit
you j'ai dit you menteur
il a pas compris il a pas compris quand
je et c'est après quand il a vu le
téléphone que je l'avais dans les mains
et là il m'a dit c'est pas pour moi
c'est ça j'ai pas destiné à moi quoi
je vous dis il y a souvent des messages
groupés mais juste il a 86 ans il est à
Marrakech il est en fin de carrière mais
il est le roi de la nuit à Marrakech il
trompe dans la même boîte de nuit dans
le même temple de la nuit de Marrakech
toutes les nuits donc je pense qu'il
dort le jour il se lève il va là-bas il
rentre à 5h du matin il est il est une
ultime fois dans sa vie le pacha comme
il a toujours été sauf que là c'est à
Marrakech je suis à Marrakech dans cette
boîte il y a pas mal de voilà et c'est
plaisir de tentation merci bien sûr vous
vous enrobez toujours bien les choses
et les politiques aux éditions plomb
merci à vous deux d'avoir été merci